yes Donald Trump is getting arrested
later but we start today with economic
news we'll get to this truck the Trump
stuff we'll have time to discuss it
tomorrow let's start with economic news
inflation has now dropped to its lowest
point in two years and as you all know I
don't like to play politics with these
economic indicators I don't play
politics with debt and deficit we have
to look at it for what it is and if you
do that you will then have no choice but
to laugh at the way that Fox News
covered this Yahoo finance reports
inflation consumer prices in May Rose at
slowest annual rate since April of 2021
that's in fact more than two years it's
25 almost 26 months the Consumer Price
Index revealed headline inflation Rose
0.1 percent over the last month and four
percent over the prior year year in May
a Slowdown from April's 0.4 month over
month increase and 4.9 percent annual
gain both measures roughly in line with
Economist forecasts so we have a chart
that you can see and of course you see
this massive inflation Spike uh that
started
um right when covid started essentially
it has now come down to levels that are
still higher than what the U.S has seen
but are equivalent to what we saw
um in 2011 lower than what we saw during
the recession in 2008 similar to numbers
we had in 2006 similar to numbers in
2001 lower than numbers in 91. so you
start to see that we are now in an
inflation range that is a little bit
higher than what we have historically
said is the target
but are very reasonable inflation
numbers is this a surprise it is not I
don't have any special predictive
ability but anybody paying attention to
the trends we saw an increase in the
rate of inflation
we saw a decrease in the increase of
that rate and then the next thing you
would expect is an actual decrease my
thought was that by the end of this
summer we would be somewhere in the four
to five range we may even once we get
June's numbers in July or July's numbers
in August we may actually see inflation
down into the high threes which is even
lower than I thought it might be or it
might stay level right around this four
percent important to understand a couple
of different things and I always explain
these things number one when people see
the number four percent very often they
think prices went up four percent in may
they did not four percent is the
inflation over the last 12 months and
what happens when you get a new month's
worth of data is that in that year
indicator you drop that thirteen month
ago number and you add the latest one so
let me give you an example the number we
got last month in May
told us what was inflation from April 22
to April 23. now that we have the main
numbers we update the 12-month indicator
and we now know what was inflation from
May 22 to May 23. it's a trailing
12-month indicator number two many
people aren't aware that based on the
standards that we have for our economies
and how we think about the economy the
goal is roughly two to three percent
inflation now you might say David why
why would we want inflation and it's
important to understand this you can
critique it by saying this is not
sustainable long term as an economy
because we can't have indefinite growth
which I would engage with you on but the
reason that a little bit of inflation is
considered good is if you have too much
inflation as we understand life becomes
unaffordable for people it can cause
spending to stop because people can't
afford things and it can cause a
recession that's if we have two much
inflation you might say well but
wouldn't deflation be good then price is
going down sounds good people can afford
things if you start seeing deflation
where things get cheaper it also causes
people not to spend in businesses not to
invest why would that be if you expect
that things will be cheaper in the
future either as an individual consumer
thinking about buying a car or as a
business thinking about doing an
expansion building a new Warehouse or
whatever the case may be if you think it
will be cheaper in the future you would
wait that waiting is a decline in
economic activity which then trickles
down and can lead to layoffs and okay so
that's what we call a deflationary
spiral that's why a little bit of
inflation is considered good that little
bit of inflation is what encourages
people to buy now rather than later
but they can still afford right now and
often a little bit of inflation is in
parallel with wage growth so that's like
the general economic view now how did
Fox News react to this news well they
think there may be too many jobs they
are pulling the labor shortage Line This
is Maria Bartiromo and Republican
Congressman buddy Carter just this
morning we will also hear from uh
treasury secretary Janet Yellen today
representative Earl buddy Carter talk to
us about what you're expecting there
because the treasury secretary uh when
we first started seeing this spike in
inflation says it was transitory what
are your thoughts on how she'll explain
uh where we're going from here
well I'm sure she'll make it out to be
as as good as she can but at the same
time we are far from out of trouble here
yes I agree the FED May pause next this
month and may not raise interest rates
but that doesn't mean they're not going
to raise him back in July we've still
got some serious problems in our economy
right labor shortage last night I had
dinner with a group of Engineers and
they were telling me we need help we
need Engineers one company said they had
1700 employees they'd hire 200 today if
they could find them we still got high
interest rates in the lobby this morning
I was talking to a young lady who said
you know I wanted to buy a new car but I
just can't afford it right now it's so
high inflation interest rates those are
the type of things that we've still got
to work on in this economy and you know
Janet Yellen will paint a pretty picture
yeah all right these people really are
pathetic the argument he's making is
there are so many businesses desperate
to hire people that it is a terrible
economy the economy must be doing
terribly because so many businesses are
saying hey let's hire because we have
demand for our products and services now
let I'll be very clear with you let's
talk about Labor shortage a labor
shortage happens when demand for workers
in a particular industry for example
exceeds the supply of workers available
with the skills required willing to work
at the wage rate that is being offered
labor shortages can be a sign of a good
economy or they can be troubling labor
shortages can have positive or negative
effects on an economy depending on the
type of Labor shortage
the duration the severity and so a labor
shortage even if that's what they are
calling it is not necessarily a bad
thing for the economy it might just
signal really strong demand for goods
and services it might create incentives
to innovate and to increase efficiency
and it might mean that employers need to
offer higher wages they love talking
about the market and supply of demand
supply and demand and what a labor
shortage May signal particularly when
you're at full employment essentially is
that businesses might need to pay a
little bit more so just saying labor
shortage isn't an argument and it is
certainly not an argument when people
like Maria Bartiromo and what was this
guy's name Buddy Carter are the ones
making that argument understand that
there is no economic indicator right now
that signals a weak economy there is
just none and we're going to continue
covering that if you've been thinking
about getting a new mattress Helix sleep
is where I would start I've been
sleeping on Helix mattresses for years
now I recommend Helix to everyone which
is why I wanted them as a sponsor if you
don't want to take my word for it Helix
has been awarded number one mattress by
both GQ and Wired Magazine and one of
the things that makes Helix unique is
their sleep quiz I didn't really know
what kind of mattress would be best for
me but you do this short sleep quiz you
answer questions about your body type
and your preferences what position you
like to sleep in and Helix will match
you with the perfect mattress for you so
you know you're actually getting
something tailored to your needs instead
of going in blind like most people do I
got my Helix mattress designed to stay
cool at night since I hate getting hot
while I sleep shipping is always free
you get 100 nights to decide whether you
like it my audience gets a huge 20
percent discount off of all orders plus
two free pillows go to Helix sleep.com
slash Pacman the link is in the
description